yet another constitutional Clash looms
over this country the UK and Scottish
governments prepare for a showdown in
the courts
laws passed here at Hollywood making it
easier to change gender something
Westminster is blocking over fears it
impacts on uk-wide equality laws we had
concerns as the UK government Secretary
of State set this out at the time
concerns about how Scotland's gender
recognition act would interact with
reserve powers about the operation of
the equalities act the protection of
women elsewhere in the UK as well the
Scottish changes speed up the existing
UK process no diagnosis of gender
dysphoria or medical reports are
required applicants must live in their
acquired gender for three months rather
than two years
16 and 17 year olds can also apply for a
gender recognition certificate for the
first time
a relief then for the trans Community to
hear the legal standoff is underway I
had a trans man I came out about five
years ago now
um and this kind of change would have
been a lot easier had it come in a bit
earlier in the sense of having the great
details for you know not having to
stress about it
um it should be just quite a minor
change in the scale of things we need
but it's become this huge big cultivar
and which is really not very nice to see
when people talk about you in those ways
Scotland's new first Minister comes a
Yusuf stood in the recent SMP election
battle on a ticket that not challenging
this in court would result in doubting
Street thinking it could run a coach and
horses through future devolve
legislation but his leadership rivals in
that contest said it's a pointless
exercise because legal advice was
suggesting the Scottish government would
lose so with so much taxpayer cash at
stake what is the right position to take
we have of course looked very seriously
at the points which the secretary of
state has raised within his order we've
of course Very looked at the detail of
that but what's important are you
confident that's that's the question
that I'm trying to get to here up to the
courts that is up to the courts as a
government are you confident of your
case well we're very confident that we
have the ability to take the judicial
regime forward the UK government said it
would not reveal its legal advice
neither side is blinking as both prepare
to ramp up the route over reforms Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh